et axel félicitations mon photo ou un
poteau ça va pas du tout ça fait
simplement un sur dix en plus accès mais
bon voilà quoi on voit un mariage et
tous et c'est la fête la plus simplement
ouais peut-être un peu plus concis plus
by axel quelle journée merveilleuse
mon couteau quoi wissam atteint
maintenant ça va pas du tout j'ai des
repères dit toi une chose c'est que ta
force c'est ta beauté
statistiquement les bogen puisque le nez
c'est pareil pour l'intelligence donc
n'hésite pas à sortir des mots comme un
visiblement ostensiblement tu bien ça
manifestement incontestablement est
assurément
et comme tu n'as ni femme ni enfant ce
qui est un vrai problème pour nous je ne
le cache pas il faut vraiment qu'on mise
tout sur ton travail tu as chercheur au
chômage
tu m'as dupe et je vais te détruire
idéologiquement ton quotidien sera un
enfer de désolation chez un débris de
mer dans l'immensité du cosmos gros gros
gros tas de merde je vais te faire
ravaler ton arrogance de petites [ __ ]
du 7e je rêve de d'écorchée vive morceau
par morceau super lentement avec un
couteau suisse aujourd'hui la joie sur
mon visage en pensant à toi d'arrêt ou
un vab gelé morte je te pleure enfin la
paix je peux tu aimais tranquillement et
quand même chier sur tâtonnements wever
malheureusement pas le temps de
continuer à lire ce recueil de poésie
oliver
la sortie des écoles présentes et ont
dit que j'arrêtais de lille et j'ai pu
couper la partie et en plus j'ai repris
mon apprentissage en pâtisserie et mais
en fait mon rêve vraiment c'est de
devenir avocat d'accord mais là entre la
drogue à pâtisserie l'avocat c'est
peut-être que je peux être ton
assistants personnels que j'ai rempli ce
jeu juste pas tomber de vie a tué 7
rennes est habitué à partir je
travaillerai avec un grand plaisir
je n'en ai enfin n'ont pas pu pas dans
ce sens là
ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pourrais être un homme de l'ombre du
moussan pas très concerné par le sexe en
ce moment tu fais panière à linge est
plutôt bon soir soit c'est moi un tel
objet 75 c'est que c'est que c'est chez
que ray
c'est vrai qu'on prend là où ça
commençait à merder chimiquement ma vie
voyez quoi pas bonne chose
je ne sais pas grand chose signifie
complètement folle
moi c'est pareil j'ai très très mal et
mme simonet c'est un ancien client que
j'ai défendue ait accusé toi la stuk il
ya rien de bon là dans ces cartes n'a
pas une petite éclaircie quelquefois
elle dit que ta attrape un couteau à
dessert et que tu a planté un coup dans
le ventre à 100 mais nord est c'est fait
ça tout seul quand je suis revenu dans
la salle des fêtes c'est une malade elle
de son côté dit que vous l'avez arracher
cette cruelle que l'amour non et de
toute façon même si j'avais voulu
j'aurais pas pu parce qu'il ne portait
pas de tumeur jeudi des sorties d'école
les ennuis je n'étudie que je cherche un
baby sitter on voit tonton jeunes homos
peur diatta plus de parts que tu sors ce
soir
non j'ai rendez vous avec un mec dans ma
chambre 1
d'accord mais je juge pas mais d'arrêt
watan avis c'est bon là je passais dans
le coin je m'en méfie quand même tu
connais le blog de convaincre comment
est-ce que tu peux révéler des choses
que s'est confiée sur mes clients c'est
quand même ironique quand on désigne
comme l'appui du barreau alors que je
suis en plein diront sexuelle parce
qu'un témoin on a pu vous apercevoir
n'ont pas de témoins humain mais jacques
la pression que de toucher le fond mais
j'ai constaté dans le fond du fond il
n'y a pas de coup je vais te faire
ravaler ton arrogance de petit pull du
7e saloperie de sociopathes de mer la
réalité va exploser à la gueule n'ont
malheureusement pas le temps de
continuer à lire se repose il s'ensuit
plus dans vos désirs pervers je suis
puissiez
je vais y aller c'est parce que tu crois
en fait moi je garde les enfants j aie
est complètement stupide
tu trouves pas que ça marche bien chez
lipp mois entre nous en fait j'ai peur
de toi te sens du drame anormalement
développer